StStéphanie, Alec et Christian,
bobonsoir.
PrPremier tour des élections
frfrançaises. Je vais vouloir vs
amamener sur les terres en disat
: : on ne peut pas faire des
rarapprochements avec lâcheté ds
grgrands partis traditionnels ms
d'd'abord, faisons-nous plaisir.
PrPremier tour des tables
susur les résultats des arrêts.
QuQu'est-ce que cela vous
inindication?
- - De surprise parce que les
dederniers sondages de cette
élélection laissaient présager e
MaMacron et Marine Le Pen serait
trtrès serrée. Emmanuel Macron
susurpasse Marine Le Pen. L'aute
susurprise c'est que le leader
MéMélenchon performe beaucoup
mimieux que prévu. Conclusion :
bobonne nouvelle.
DéDéception pour Marine Le Pen.
RiRien de décédé et on va tous
écécouter le débat que Marine Le
PePen avait raté il y a cinq ans
mamais il faut qu'ils réussisse.
- - Stéphanie?
- - On avait peur que les votes
popour le rassemblement national
prprennent de l'ampleur et
coconsidérant que contrairementn
202017, Éric Zemmour se plaçaità
lala droite que Marine Le Pen et
quque ça puisse dédoubler les
élélecteurs à la droite.
CeCela ne s'est pas matérialisé
dadans la façon dont les prévoyt
dadans les sondages.
BoBonne nouvelle. Ce sera
inintéressant de voir surtout ls
vovotes Mélenchon, 22 % qui ont
vovoté pour lui est-ce qu'ils vt
réréellement aller vers Monsieur
MaMacron ou rester à la maison?
- - Pour ne pas répéter ce que s
cocollègues ont déjà vais vous
didire ce qui m'a étonné c'est
l'l'effondrement total des deux
grgrands partis historiques
frfrançais depuis 58 et se
papartager le pouvoir jusqu'à
tetemps que Emmanuel Macron ente
enen scène en 2017. Les partis
sosocialistes avaient moins de %
etet les républicains qui fêtent
momoins de 5 %. C'est quand mêm,
cecela place les deux grands
papartis dans la catégorie des
esespèces en péril. Ils seront s
cacapables de se faire remboursr
leleurs dépenses, alors c'est ue
cacatastrophe pour ces deux gras
papartis. Ce qui laisse toute la
vovoie à Macron et aux autres
paparties qui sont plus à droite
ouou plus à gauche. Les extrême,
c'c'est comme un fer à cheval.ÀA
drdroite et à gauche on se rejot
ququelque part dans un anti
sysystème, une rhétorique.
LeLes parties traditionnelles un
pepeu comme ici.
- - Poursuivez là-dessus et
StStéphanie écrit en, un peu coe
icici, les parties
trtraditionnelles, OK, au fédér,
ilil y a eu réunion de la droit,
onon verra si ça va tenir. Maisu
QuQuébec, Monsieur Legault un pu
cocomme Monsieur Macron qui estu
cecentre gauche et droite, et ne
lalaisse pas beaucoup de place à
d'd'autres parties
trtraditionnelles.
- - Non et ce qu'on a vu dans ls
dederniers mois c'est la montée
dedes règles du même, le parti
coconservateur du Québec,
sosolidaire se débrouille plutôt
bibien dans son créneau. La CAQ,
c'c'est nouveau. Les Parti
ququébécois et libéral souffre
bebeaucoup du fait qu'ils sont à
dedepuis longtemps et que les
élélecteurs ont cherché de la
nonouveauté mais du fait qu'ils
n'n'ont pas été capables de
rerenouveler leur discours et de
trtrouver la tête d'affiche qui
ététait au diapason. C'est
bebeaucoup plus difficile pour
LéLéon Canada anglais, au fédér,
ilil faudra voir comment Pierre
PoPoilièvre se débrouille. Une
tetentative de harnacher m'en du
paparti conservateur traditionnl
papar les droites populistes. On
atattaque la banque du Canada, n
a a toutes sortes de fantasmes u
ccôté des Pierre Poilièvre et
c'c'est un discours aussi anti
sysystème. La différence c'est
ququ'il est à l'intérieur d'un
grgrand parti traditionnel maisl
sasait aussi assez vague anti
sysystème quasi populaire dans
bibien des pays.
- - Christian, le sort des
paparallèles que l'on peut faire
avavec des parties ici qui en
ararrachent.
- - Je suis réservé par rapportà
seses parallèles. Le système
frfrançais est tellement
fofondamentalement différent du
sysystème canadien et québécoisn
cece qui a trait aux parties coe
tetelle. On sait que dans notre
rérégime, tout repose sur les
paparties. Le premier ministre s
élélu pour l'ensemble de la
popopulation passait les chefs s
paparties ququi contrôlent la
chchambre. Si Monsieur Legault
nonous quittait, le premier
miministre du Québec et serait
l'l'homme ou la femme qui serait
chchoisie par la claque.
ReRenouvellement des parties mas
c'c'est très vigoureux. En Frane
c'c'est autre chose. C'est que
dedepuis que l'on a mis fin...
dedepuis que l'élection en Fran,
cocoïncide avec la législation,
c'c'est asphyxié. Les socialist,
cecela fait le processus comme
tetelle. Je pars le niveau
nanational. En France, le
prproblème, c'est que les
cacandidats ont tendance à se
fafaire leur partie
auautomatiquement et ce n'est ps
çaça les dessin ne vient pas de
llà-bas. Honnêtement, je trouve
papas qu'il y a beaucoup
d'd'analogie apparaît.
- - Très bien.
- - Écoutez, c'est certain qu'iy
a a peut-être certains parallèls
afaffaires au sein de la société
cicivile. À Tahoua on a vu le
coconvoi et Monsieur Macron
ququelques années a fait face ax
lélégendes qui sont les mouvemes
ququi émanent de cette
prprotestation du système de
l'l'anti système. Mais c'est un
pepeu un cercle vicieux pour les
nonouveaux partis politiques qui
sese créent c'est-à-dire qu'ells
dedevront faire face au système
évéventuellement est rentrées ds
leles moules il y a déception et
onon retourne dans le secret.
C'C'est normal. Cela fait parti
dedes systèmes démocratiques qul
y y a un renouveau qui se place
susur l'échiquier à la gauche
cocomme à droite. Éventuellemen,
ilil y a toujours un ressac et n
fifinit par jamais s'en sortir.
- - Donc, on est via cette coure
àà la direction du parti
coconservateur. Est-ce que
ulultimement on pourra recoller
leles deux ou trois fractions de
cece parti? Voici Monsieur
ChCharest.
IlIl a décliné attaquer et pas
PiPierre Poilièvre. Et, il
atattaque.
EsEst-ce qu'on va entendre, sur
l'l'public a donné Pierre
PoPoilièvre au camionneur à
TaTahoua.
JEJEAN CHAREST, candidat à la d.
PaParti conservateur du Canada.
- - Honnêtement, quand j'observe
lala façon dont il conduit
sasa course au leadership,
jeje pense qu'il y a des enjeux
dede jugement. Je vais vous donr
unun exemple, quand il y a eu
l'l'affaire des camionneurs sur
lala colline Parlementaire,
ilil y a eu un blocus. Bien,
MoMonsieur Poilièvre a appuyé,
a a soutenu un blocus qui a eu
dedes conséquences très directes
susur l'économie canadienne,
ququi était illégal.
LLà, il fait la promotion
dede la cryptomonnaie. Il attaqe
lala Banque du Canada, la monnae
cacanadienne. Et moi, j'essaie
dede suivre et de comprendre,
etet honnêtement, je trouve que
c'c'est plutôt inquiétant comme
prproposition pour le pays.
- - Alec, il va attaquer de plus
enen plus Monsieur Poilièvre pae
quque Monsieur Poilièvre ne s'et
jajamais gêné. Il les voit bien
ququ'il faut qu'elle rattrape du
teterrain perdu aussi.
- - Oui et c'est une stratégie
dédélibérée. Ce n'est pas un
hahasard que Gean Charest t se t
ananimés à cette question. Je li
rereçue à mon émission vendredit
unune entrevue tout à fait
clclassique d'aspirant à la
chchefferie conservatrice de
ququelqu'un qui veut devenir
prpremier ministre polaire arrie
dadans la conversation.
C'C'est le stimule et on agent
chchar est plus bagarreur. Celui
ququ'on a connu en politique un
pepeu moins éteint que dans les
dedernières semaines et ça lui
sesert mieux et il se qu'il faut
ququ'elle soit à l'offensive pae
quque clairement Pierre Poiliève
ététait en tête et il faut qu'il
gagagne du terrain. Oui Pierre
PoPoilièvre fait cela par les
crcryptomonnaie et le qu'on voit
paparce que il veut aller chercr
lala liberté à rien, la fibre
pepeut-être plus liberté aryenne
dudu parti conservateur et amenr
dede nouveaux membres. En même
tetemps cela conservateur, encoe
unune base très traditionnelle
coconservatrice qui est
prprobablement un peu incertaine
d'd'où il s'en va avec la
crcryptomonnaie, le fait que la
loloi et l'ordre ne soit pas une
prpriorité.
UnUn moment donné ce qu'aller
chchercher une frange pour
s's'assurer de gagner ou de
nonouveaux membres au centre de
gagagner pour s'aliéner, Jean cr
esest a besoin pour gagner. Il
pepeut pas aller jouer dans les
mmêmes plates-bandes.
IlIl doit l'attaquer et doit fae
prprendre conscience de son
pepersonnage et le temps commene
àà presser. Les débats s'en
viviennent et il place la table
popour les deux débats de la
sesemaine prochaine Stéphanie.
C'C'est intéressant.
- - C'est un buzz word. Il se
ququ'il va aller capter
l'l'attention et n'a qu'à dire
cecela mais en dis pas plus. Ila
chchercher des adeptes.
- - Oui, la cryptomonnaie pour
rérégler l'inflation en pourrait
paparler à quelqu'un pour lui
dedemander si ça va fonctionner.
OnOn connaît sa réponse. C'est
inintéressant de voir à quel pot
MoMonsieur Poilièvre et Monsieur
ChCharest s'en vont en direction
opopposée dans cette course.
C'C'est-à-dire que Monsieur
PoPoilièvre se veut un candidat
plplus radical qui va même toucr
pepeut-être aller tenter de tene
lala main aux électeurs
coconservateurs qui ont quitté a
papartie avec Maxime Bernier,
atattendu que Monsieur Charest
s's'en va plus vers le centre et
vava tenter d'aller chercher des
vovotes des libéraux bleus, des
gegens qui sont tannés du règne
lilibéral à Ottawa mais qui ne
sosont pas prêts à embarquer das
leles wagons avec Poilièvre. Por
lele moment, si l'on en croit ls
fofoules, que Monsieur Poilièvre
atattire, c'est sa stratégie qui
fofonctionne. Est-ce qu'il y a
ququand même des membres du pari
coconservateur de longue date qi
dodoive être en réflexion.
- QuQu'est-ce que cela vous
ininspire Christian c'est de
pepersonnalité, discours
didifférent?
- - On peut comprendre leur
frfrançais. C'est un progrès.
SoSouvent, on devait faire des
efefforts. Plus sérieusement, dn
ccôté on a quelqu'un qui
rereprésentait la droite dure, à
l'l'américaine et de l'autre côé
onon a un progressiste
coconservateur. Comment concilir
leles deux. Je dois dire que
j'j'écoutais l'entrevue à tout e
momonde en parle et je trouve qe
c'c'était décevant. C'est bien
bebeau d'avoir le piton collé sr
lele passé mais je entendrai sur
cece qu'elle veut voir l'avenir.
C'C'est important.
- - En quoi il serait différente
JuJustin Trudeau.
- - On n'en a pas parlé assez. t
MoMonsieur Charlet était frustré
dede cela. L'enjeu était
imimportant. Je reçois de bonnes
chchances parce que dans une
dédémocratie libérale important
quque l'on est deux grands parts
popour l'alternance. Ce n'est ps
fafait parce que il y a un gros
écécart entre les deux tendances
quque c'est difficile à savoir
cocomment le rencontrer cecela.
- - Très bien. Dure semaine pour
lele gouvernement Legault. On a
étété replongé dans l'affreuse
hihistoire de Herron avec des
dédétails et qui savait quoi.
VoVoici Monsieur Legault, qui
acaccuse l'opposition d'avoir
ininjustement attaqué Madame Bls
etet Mme McCann. Alors que la
nonouvelle de leur départ a été
évévitée avant que les deux
prprincipales ne le fassent.
- - Je trouve ça odieux de tenir
dedes propos comme ça parce qu'n
a a les partis de l'opposition,
pependant toute la semaine,
ququi ont blâmé Danielle McCannt
MaMarguerite Blais et tout à co,
viviennent à la défense de
DaDanielle McCann et Marguerite
BlBlais, mais je peux vous assur
quque c'est pas personne de
momon entourage qui a fait coulr
cecette information-là. Je troue
çaça triste qu'on fasse de la
pepetite politique parce qu'il a
unune élection partielle
auaujourd'hui. Je pense qu'il ft
fafaire le lien entre ce
sasalissage-là qu'on a eu sur
totoute la semaine. Je trouve ça
ododieux, je trouve ça,
frfranchement, là, petite
popolitique de bas étage.
- - Attendez quand le rapport de
lala coronaire va sortir.
ChChristian?
- - Monsieur Legault je les troe
cacandides. Même si c'est un vix
vévétéran de la politique il y a
unune naïveté réelle précédant a
nanature des choses que ce soit
çaça. C'est une élection
papartielle. Cela arrive au bon
momoment pour l'opposition. Cela
rarappelle que la pandémie, la
gegestion était bonne mais il ya
eueu un élément de déshonneur qi
s's'incarne dans Marguerite Blas
etet Mme McCann dans les bilans
n'n'est pas Christian Dubé.
CeCela sort au mauvais moment.
CeCette élection peut donner le
toton à l'élection générale qui
s's'en vient. Mais c'est normal.
C'C'est un combat et politique.n
atattaque le gouvernement.
- - François Legault n'y allait
papas de mémoire qu'elle était
dadans les parties de l'oppositn
àà l'époque. Il attaquait
dudurement les gouvernements. Qe
cece soit celui de Jean Chareste
PhPhilippe Couillard.
IlIl est aussi capable d'y aller
popour la jugulaire.
IlIl a pas de doute que la
mamajorité de la population pene
quque le gouvernement en fonctin
dede ce qu'elle savait au moment
ouoù cela se produisait a fait e
mimieux qu'il pouvait, que ce
sosoient les deux femmes ou
MoMonsieur Legault. Le contexte
ététait très turbulent avec
bebeaucoup d'essayage ça été en
didifficulté et encore plus loin
popour un CHSLD privé.
ToToujours plus de relief. C'est
unun déshonneur. L'opposition ne
vava pas se priver. De la même
mamanière qu'on va chercher les
ananecdotes pour incarner les
didifficultés du gouvernement ds
lala gestion de ceci ou de cela.
IlIl y a une question de maman
ététant donné l'élection
papartielle. En plus, élection
gégénérale et que les parties
vovoient bien que Legault...
ilil faut l'écorcher.
- - Stéphanie, vous êtes d'accod
quque c'est inévitable dans le u
popolitique mais pas les jeux...
c'c'est normal que l'opposition
popose des questions difficiles.
- - Les portes de position vont
fafaire feu de tout bois. Cela a
dodonné que les nouvelles de la
sesemaine dernière la a randonnn
bebeau cadeau pour les élections
papartielles dans Marie-Victorin
d'd'autant plus que l'on est
prprésentement dans une sixième
vavague est d'autant plus que la
clclaque est allée chercher une
cacandidate qui sort du milieu e
lala santé pour se présenter das
cecette circonscription et donc
cecela aurait été assez difficie
dedevant l'opposition n'a pas
acaccroché à cette histoire cela
fofonctionné dans la dernière
sesemaine. C'est peut-être odiex
dudu point de vue de la carte ms
dadans l'opposition, ils auraiet
fafait la même chose.
- - Élection partielle dans Mar-
ViVictorin. On va suivre ça en
didirect avec Anne-Marie ce soi.
QuQui a le plus à perdre ou l'ps
àà gagner? Tous les stratèges
vovont prendre des notes. On esà
sisix mois de la générale. Toure
tatable. Christian.
- - Je vais suivre beaucoup de
chchoses. Pour les PQ, châteaux
foforts depuis des années. Est-e
quque les PQ est mort?
UnUne partielle ne représente ps
totout. Pour une fois qu'on a ue
élélection on va voir sur le
teterrain. Qu'est-ce que cela va
dodonner? Très intéressant.
- - Qui a le plus à gagner?
PoPour les PQ, ce serait au de s
gagarder cela.
- - Je pense que celui qui jouee
plplus gros et les Parti québécs
paparce qu'elle était à la
cicirconscription et il a trouvé
unun bon candidat. On se demande
auaux enfants c'est parti. On se
popose des questions sur la sure
dede ce parti que de celle de la
cAcAQ. On va surveiller ce parti
auaussi. Ça risque d'être assez
seserré. Les autres ne sont pas
dadans la course. On a beau
reregarder avec une loupe ça ree
quque c'est une course entre la
CACAQ et les PQ.
- - Le taux de participation de5
% % à 16 heures. Stéphanie.
QuQuelques secondes.
- - Ce n'est pas une
cicirconscription baromètre. C't
dédéfinitivement les PQ à l'pluà
peperdre surtout considérant la
sisituation dans laquelle il se
rere